cymbals cymbals are a new data type in
es6 a cymbal is a unique and immutable
data type they're tokens that may be
used as unique IDs you create symbols
via the factory function symbol just
like that you can also create simples
with a text and aside the parentheses a
string the only purpose of the string
inside the parenthesis there is just
identified a symbol another thing
interesting about symbols is that they
are always unique for instance if we do
and if we run that it's going to be
false but also if we put symbol to so
you can see they both have the name
symbol too and we run that again and
it's still gonna be false symbols are
always unique they never equal each
other no matter what and if we check the
type of the symbol it's always simple
see another thing interesting about
symbols is that if you try to convert a
symbol to a string always throws an
exception so if you do if you just tried
to add a string with a symbol it's gonna
throw a type error do not get air you
would actually have to explicitly
convert that to a string and now you can
see its symbol colon symbol 12 that's
all this is how it looks when it gets
converted to a string there are two main
use cases I want to talk about symbols
are mainly used as unique property keys
because the symbol never clashes with
any other property either a symbol or a
string so if you look at this use case
one symbols as property keys you can see
the constant my key equal symbol is
created and let object just create an
object and then if you add the key to
the object then if you just console dot
log the key in the object we just run
that you will see one two three and it's
always going to
be unique another use case is Constance
representing concepts so if you create
constants for all these different colors
then you can use these constants in your
code so every time you call symbol read
a new symbol is created so one symbol
red is not the same as another symbol
red therefore color red this color red
can never be mistaken for another value
and that would be different if it were
the string red the string red could be
mistaken for another value but this
color is every time you put color red
it's not going to be the same as a
variable that's just equal to red as a
string thanks for watching my name is
beau Carnes check the description for
links to more information about symbols
don't forget to subscribe and remember
and remember use your code for good